Capcom's Yoshinori owner has said an
Onimusha revival is in the discussion
phase noting the Japanese company is
aware of the popularity of the franchise
with fans and wants to bring back old
favorites I'm Lucy and welcome to this
fan favorite GameSpot news update
speaking in an interview with The Daily
Star Ono who served as producer on the
samurai versus demons action game series
indicated returning to the property was
something that he's interested in he
added that he discussed a potential
revival with members of the series
development team capcom as a company
know we have many brands IPS and series
that are beloved by players around the
world and we always have found asking
when is this or that coming back I've
spoken internally with people who made
only Musha with me originally and talked
about maybe how interesting it would be
to revisit that series otto emphasized
that currently a new owner wish of
project had not progressed past the
early discussion phase as he was too
busy in street fights of 5 to half the
battles necessary to get the ball
rolling he says right now I'm so focused
on Street Fighter 5 that I'm not really
in a position to start that same level
of battle that I had to have to get
Street Fighter 4 made all I can do for
now is reassure fires that conversations
are happening at high levels we realize
the need for different series to maybe
come back into the forefront and
although there's nothing to talk about
right now I'm sure in the future there
will be news on a variety of series that
will keep the fans happy fan favorites
are going to come back in December 2015
Capcom registered a new trademark for
Onimusha the trademark was not a renewal
but an entirely new registration
sparking speculation that the
playstation 2 era action game series may
be making a comeback so what do you
reckon should Capcom be focusing on the
fan favorites or do you want to see some
new and fresh I please let me know in
the comments box below or come find me
on Twitter I'm a Lucy James games for
the latest keep it GameSpot